hey guys it is Friday which means I've
got the biggest stories of the whole
week to get you all caught up on what's
been going on here's what mattered fess
up Tekken director katsuhiro harada have
spoken up about Tekken 7 and the street
fighter 5 input lag controversy a number
of players who claimed that Street
Fighter fives input lag is a massive
issue on ps4 Capcom replied by saying
they're looking into the reports but it
sounds like Harada has had it with the
complaints saying since when did
everyone become so knowledgeable about
input lag if everyone is so sensitive to
this of course you know exactly how many
frames of input lag there were in past
titles I have a feeling many people are
just prone to being swayed by popular
cash words he emphasized that input lag
is in his opinion not a problem for
tekken 7 saying he has not heard any
complaints so far this week a whole
bunch of info was data mined from the
battlefield one closed alpha among the
leaked info are the 20 chapter titles of
battlefield single-player campaign which
make up the game 7 episodes there are
also a whole lot of ways you can get
special dog tags which include
completing roads battlefield 1 missions
in battlefield 4 or HUD line merely
owning a previous battlefield game or
attending a battlefield one event there
will be over 30 weapons including
handguns cavalry weapons and so-called
behemoth weapons as well as a bunch of
gadgets that will include mines medic
bags and gas masks if you want even more
spoiler epic info you can find details
on maps melee weapons and game modes you
know story on gamespot Bethesda has
confirmed that fallout 4s upcoming nucca
world DLC will be the last one in a
Twitter exchange Bethesda marketing
executive Pete Hines confirmed that
fallout 4 players should not expect any
more DLC expansions after nuke award
lands in August nucca world is set in a
post-apocalyptic amusement park and will
add new weapons and quests before that
the vault-tec workshop add-on is
arriving later this month which will let
you build your own bolts both of these
are included with the fifty-dollar plot
for dlc past this week it was announced
that red dead redemption would be coming
to Xbox one it through backwards
compatibility and it
none of you guys could find your old
copies because you've been buying the
hell out of it on Amazon just after the
announcement earlier this week sales of
red dead redemption game of the year
edition climbed over thirty thousand
percent in amazon sales rankings while
sales of the digital xbox 360 code
jumped over ten thousand percent the
game is also currently on sale as part
of Microsoft's annual ultimate game sale
for seven dollars fifty if you're an
xbox live gold member and fraternal is
50 for everybody else the only two games
are received more votes from people
calling for them to be made backwards
compatible I'll call of duty black ops 2
and Skyrim finally a mobile game came
out this week that people actually seem
to care about probably because it's got
pokemon in the day Pokemon go started
rolling out this week beginning in
Australia and New Zealand if you're
wondering what all the fuss is about we
have all sorts of impressions and tips
you can check out on gamespot but it
hasn't been all sunshine and roses for
the game's launch the free-to-play game
has a lot of bugs at the moment
including frequent crashes heavy battery
drain and messed up audio since the game
requires you to walk around in the real
world staring at your phone Australian
police in the Northern Territory
published a Facebook post asking players
to please look up from their phones to
avoid walking into posts or traffic and
to bleed stop coming into the police
station to grab more pokeballs noting
that it works just as well from the
outside of the building this week on
site you can check out our video on the
best console exclusives shown off at e3
this year we chat about what we think
about battlefield 1 and what the best
games of 2016 have been so far that is
everything I've got for you this week
but do let me know if you're going to be
playing pokemon go or whatever else this
weekend and I will see you again on
Monday